let's keep taking calls we will go next
to the caller from the 905 area code
caller what is your name and where you
calling from hi my name's a longhorn
kappa awesome what's on your mind all
david were campaigning on the wall that
dog comes kind of built my opinion is it
will not happen my opinion is he will
probably figure out a way to get some
fencing built on some piece of the
southern border between the u.s. and
Mexico and he will call it a success
probably a lot of his supporters will
buy into it and say look Trump built the
wall but the the wall across the entire
border that he said he would build and
that Mexico would pay for just not going
to happen and you'll notice I don't know
if you I'm sure you guys have have been
realizing this in Canada as we have here
that there's been a lot less talk about
the wall recently yeah yeah all right
well listen great question always great
to hear from our friendly neighbors to
the north in Canada uh really appreciate
the call I would not hold my breath for
that wall that Donald Trump talked about
building